وصف الرئيس الصيني اوشي جينج وضع الامن
القومي لبلاده بانه معقد وخطير ودعا
للاستعداد الى ما سماه اسوا سيناريوهات
ياتي هذا بعد ايام فقط من تقارير صينيه عن
هجمات سيبرانيه امريكيه على البنيه
التحتيه لبيجين وبالتزامن مع رفض الصين
عقد لقاء بين وزير دفاعها ونظيره الامريكي
كان مقررا في سنغافوره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما ابرز المؤشرات التي
دفعت الرئيس الصيني لتصحيح بان وضع امن
بلاده القومي معقد وخطير وما مغزى كشفه عن
هذا الوضع ثم ما سياقات تصاعد حده الرسائل
المتبادله بين بيجي وواشنطن واخرها كان
الاعتذار الصيني علقاء وزير الدفاع
الامريكي وتبادل الاتهامات
بالاستفزاز في بحر جنوب الصين ثم ما مال
الات هذا التصعيد وكيف سينعكس على الاوضاع
في بحر جنوب الصين وما يشهده من توترات
وما تاثير ذلك كله على الامن والاستقرار
الدوليين
[موسيقى]
بعد ايام من اتهامي بيجين واشنطن بالتخطيط
لشهر هجمات الكترونيه على مسمتها البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه للصين نقلت صحيفه الشعب
اليوميه الرسميه عن الرئيس
قوله ان وضع الامن القومي لبلاده
معقد وخطير
واضفت الصحيفه ان الرئيس الصينية دعا خلال
اجتماع دوري للجنه المركزيه للحزب الشيوعي
الى الاستعداد لاسوء سيناريوهات وفق ما
نقلت عنه الصحيفه
تصريحات تتزامن مع رفض بجين اجتماعا بين
اجتماعا بين وزير دفاعها ونظيره الامريكي
كان مقررا في سنغافوريا سنغافوره عفوا
الامر الذي اعتبرته واشنطن مؤسفا لكن
الصين التي اكدت اهميه العلاقات العسكريه
مع الولايات المتحده وان الاتصالات بين
جيشي البلدين لن تنقطع قالت في الوقت نفسه
ان قرار رفض اجتماعي وزير الدفاع مرده
صعوبات مصدرها الجانب الامريكي الذي
اتهمته بتجاهل المخاوف الصينيه واختلاق
العقبات وهو ما اعتبرته امرا يقوض بشكل
خطير الثقه المتبادله
واضافت بجين ان على واشنطن اظهار صدقها
وتصحيح اخطائها وتهيئه الظروف والاجواء
اللازمه للتواصل والتبادل بين الجانبين
وفق قولها
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الدكتور خليل العناني استاذنا والعلاقات
الدوليه ومن موسكو ينضم الينا الدكتور
محمود الحمزه الاكاديمي والباحث في الشؤون
الاسيويه اهلا بكما
ادى معك في موسكو دكتور الحمزه
يعني معقد خطير
بهذين او هاتين الكلمتين وصف الرئيس
الصيني وضع الامن القومي في بلاده ما هي
المؤشرات التي يستند اليها برايك هذا
التقييم
تحيه لك ولضيوفك الكرام ولجميع المشاهدين
الحقيقه ان الصراع
الاستراتيجي والجو سياسي بين الصين
والولايات المتحده يعني واضح للجميع هناك
حرب ومنافسه وحرب تجاريه
واقتصاديه وجيوسيه يعني هو صراع على
المصالح ليس طبعا الصراع المظاهر العسكريه
هي مثل المناورات والتحالفات المختلفه
التي قامتها امريكا في المنطقه الاسيويه
اقصد والتي تتحسس منها الصيني بالاضافه
الى مشكله تايوان التي يعني هي عقده بين
الصين والولايات المتحده كل هذه الضغوطات
من اجل فرض بعض التنازلات على الصين من
الجانب الاقتصادي والتجاري لان هناك في
يعني قرارات صينيه
استهدفت شركه مايكرو تكنولوجيا الامريكيه
والتي ستؤدي الى خساره بعشرات مليارات من
الدولارات طبعا وقد تكون هناك ايضا هدف
اخر يعني
الضغوطات على الصين التي اعلن عنها الرئيس
الصيني في مجال الامن السيبراني وبشكل عام
يعني قال الامن معقد وخطير قد يكون الضغط
على الصين لكي لا
تفكر بمساعده
نسمعه كنسمعك دكتور حمزه
نسمعك بشكل واضح
يبدو ان الدكتور حمزه لا يسمعنا انتقل الى
واشنطن خليل العلاني ان نعود دائما الى
هذه التصريحات تصريحات الرئيس الصيني
بان الوضع الامني للصين معقد وخطير لكن
اضاف الى ذلك ان الصين تستعد لاسوا
السيناريوهات ماذا نفهم من اسوا
السيناريوهات ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث
كالسيناريوهات
انا اعتقد جزء رئيسي من فهم تصريحات
الرئيس الصيني حاليا متعلق برؤيته للعالم
وممكن ان نسميه عقيده رئيس الصين
تقوم على ثلاث عوامل الرئيسيه على ثلاث
محاور رئيسيه المحور الاول يقوم على تعزيز
الصعود الصيني اقتصاديا وتجاريا والذي
مستوى مستمر منذ على الاقل عبقرين من
الزمن الامر الثاني متعلق بوحده الاراضي
الصينيه وفي القلب من ذلك هو ضم تايوان
سواء طوعا او قصرا وهذا يعتبر خط احمر
للصين وخصل رئيس تشيجن بنج والذي جاء على
خلفيه هذه المساله جوز رئيس من الشريعاته
الداخليه التي عززها على مدار اخر عشر
سنوات
وهيملتيه على الحزب الشيوعي الصيني واعاده
ترتيب الاوضاع الداخليه بحيث اصبح الرئيس
المتحكمه المهيمن متعلق بهذا الوعد الذي
اتقطع عن نفسه هو عدم السماح على الاطلاق
بانفصال تايوان واعتبر دوله مستقل هذا
يعتبر في القلب من استراتيجيته للامن
القومي الصيني الامر الثاني المتعلق
بمواجهه النفو الاقليمي الامريكي الموجود
سواء في بحر الصين الجنوبي مع الدول
متعدده سواء كان
الدول زي الفلبين زي اندونيسيا زي ماليزيا
زي اليابان او في بحر الصيني للشرقي
وبالتالي هناك حاجه صينيه حسب رؤيه
تمدد الامريكي هناك حتى وانطلب الامر
الدخول في بعض المواجهه العسكريه او
المروه العسكريه التي قد تمنع هذا هذا
التمدد ايضا جزء منه متعلق برضع امريكا في
مساله قيام او انشاء تحالفات نعلم جميعا
ان هناك تحالفات تم انشاء على مدار اخر
اربع خمس سنوات مثلا على سبيل المثال
تحالف اقواس او عكاس والذي يضم الى جانب
امريكا استراليا وبريطانيا ايضا تحالف
الاربعه الذي يضم الهند الذي ضم الهند
واستراليا واليابان وامريكا وبالتالي هذا
يعتبر من وجهه نظر الصين نعم والاكواد
ايضا يعتبر تحالف موجه للصيره وبالتالي
هناك قناه على رئيس الحالي بان هناك
حان الوقت من اجل مواجهه الصعود او من اجل
مواجهه التمدد الامريكي في المنطقه
وبالتالي الدخول امكانيه الدخول في مواجهه
قد تكون عسكريه في المستقبل
هل هذا اسوا دكتور حمزه هل هذا اسوء
سيناريو تفكر فيه او يتحدث عنه الصين بشكل
الرئيس الصيني بشكل غير مباشر
نعم يعني هو الحقيقه يعني اشارات او تهديد
او تعبير عن استعداد الصين للمجابه بما
فيها العسكريه ولكن بتقديري ان المجابهه
العسكريه بين الصين وامريكا كما قال هنري
ستكون دمار للعالم لانه الصين دوله قويه
بكل معنى الكلمه اقتصاديا وعسكريا
والولايات المتحده ايضا معروفه هي الدوله
الاولى في العالم لذلك الصراع لن يصل الى
عسكري
مباشر ومفتوح وانما هي ضغوطات يعني عن
طريق احلاف عن طريق مناورات وهي تكمل
الصراع والمنافسه الاقتصاديه والتجاريه
بين البليدين اعتقد ستستمر في هذا الاطار
وكانت هناك فكره لدي لكن انقطع الخط انه
هذه الضغوطات على الصين الامريكيه اقصد قد
يكون الهدف منها ايضا يعني
لكي لا تفكر الصين بتقديم الدعم العسكري
لروسيا في اوكرانيا
هذا ايضا مساله حساسه لان الغرب والولايات
المتحده
قبل حرب نعم لكن العلاقه كانت متازمه حتى
قبل الحرب حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا وعلى
اوكرانيا
نعم هي ليست سببها اوكرانيا بدون شك عم
بقول يمكن عامل اضافي يعني قد يدخل في هذا
الموضوع لكن التوسع الصيني الهائل
نعم دكتور هل ترى ان الاتهامات الصينيه
اتهامات واقعيه يعني عندما يقول الرئيس
الصيني او عندما تاتي هذه التصريحات بعد
اتهام بيجين لواشنطن بالتخطيط لشن هجمات
سيبرانيه امريكيه ضد ما سمته بجين بالبنيه
التحتيه
الحيويه للصين هل هذه تهديدات تبدو لك
واقعيه
لا اعتقد ذلك انا اعتقد ان هذه الرسائل قد
تكون ايضا موجهه للداخل الصيني يعني
الرئيس الصيني يريد ان يحصل على تجميع
وتوحيد المجتمع الصيني وتراس المجتمع
الصيني حوله تحت شعار خطر خارجي هذا شعار
يستخدموا كل الدول ان هناك خطر هجمات
مختلفه ومن
الامن
يكون هناك فيها هجمات معينه نعم واشنطن
كيف دكتور خليل كيف تستقبل واشنطن هذه
الاتهامات اتهامات بجيل لها بالتخطيط
لهجمات سيبرانيه ضد
مصالح حيويه صينيه
اولا اتهامات بين الطرفين المتبادل على
مدار الفتره الاخيره ايضا قبل حوالي يومين
كانت هناك اتهامات امريكيه لقيام الصين
بتخطيط لهجمات سيبرانيه على ايضا البنيه
تحتيه امريكيه بل هناك ايضا اجراءات تم
اتخاذها امريكيا ضد مجموعه من الشركات
الصينيه على شركه هاواي التي تتهم من قبل
امريكا بالقيام بالتجسس الامريكيين هناك
ايضا حظر كما تعلم جميع التطبيق تيك توك
الشهير الذي يعتبر يعني تكنولوجيا الصينيه
هناك مخاوف من يكون هذا التطبيق يقوم بجمع
او بلم معلومات او تجميع معلومات عن
مسؤولين امريكيين واستخدامها في الصراع مع
امريكا لكن الامر ايضا متعلق بالصوره
الاكبر خديجه امريكا تضع الصين باعتبارها
تحديا استراتيجيا استراتيجيا لامريكا على
المستوى المتواصل ومستوى من والثقل الامن
الاستراتيجي القومي الامريكي اخرها كان في
اكتوبر الماضي عندما تحدث وزير الدفاع عن
تحداني استراتيجيا يجب التصدي له بكل
الاشكال وهذا يعتبر جزء ايضا او اسباب رفض
الصين الالتقاء عليه باعتبار تصريحاته
بشكل او باخر عدائيه تجاه الصين خلال
الفتره الماضيه الامر الاخر ايضا متعلق
بهذا الصراع العالمي حول الهيمنه وحول
النفوس هناك الصراع امريكا الصيني متصاعد
هناك حديث امريكي متزايد سواء حق عن باطل
بان صعود الصين لنكون صعودا سلميا هناك
حديث كثيره جدا حول الخطر الصيني جزء منه
ايضا متعلق بالصراع الداخلي في امريكا
والمتعلق بمحاوله ايجاد بالاستمرار عدو
خارجي كان في الماضي والعدو الاحمر
بما انك شرطي الى يعني لقاء وزيري الدفاع
الصيني والامريكي والصين كما هو معروف
طبعا بررت رفض لقاء وزير دفاعيها مع وزير
الدفاع الامريكي في سنغافوره بما سمته
تجاهل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
للمخاوف الصينيه هل تدرك واشنطن بالفعل
طبيعه المخاوف الصينيه
لا اعتقد ذلك واشنطن كما قلت قبل قليل
الاستراتيجيتك قائم على التحفز وفي بعض
الاوقات كمان الاستفزاز بمعنى اخر عندما
ننظر على سبيل المثال اذا اخذنا قضيه
تايوان على سبيل المثال الثابت فسات
الامريكان خلال 4 4 عقود مضت كان يتعلق
بما يسمى بسياسه الغموض الاستراتيجي بمعنى
عدم الاعتراف بتايوان دوله مستقله بس بنفس
الوقت كمان عدم السماح بضمها للصين خلال
اخر سنتين ثلاثه هناك تحول ما في الموقف
الامريكي من هذه القضيه على سبيل المثال
مثلا عندما تقوم الرئيسيه مجلس النواب
الامريكي نانسي بلوسي الرئيس طبعا السابقه
المجلس النواب تقوم بزياره تايوان في
اغسطس الماضي تعتبر اعلى زياره لاعلى
مسؤوله امريكا ده يعتبر استفزاز عندما
تستقبل او يستقبل كيفن مكارسي رئيس
الاغلبيه في حزب في مجلس النواب الامريكي
رئيس التايوان خلال قبل حوالي شهر من الان
في كاليفورنيا هذا يعتبر الاستفزاز للصين
هناك ايضا دعم عسكري لاول مره يعتبر تحول
في تقديم اسلحه نوعيه تايوان
امريكي للصين وبالتالي جزر من هذه الازمه
متعلق بما تقوم به امريكا في تلك المنطقه
من العالم هناك توجد عسكري امريكي كفيف
هناك على الاقل مثلا اذا خدنا هناك على
الاقل 25 الف جندي في قاعده
اليابانيه هناك وجود عسكري امريكي في
كوريا الجنوبيه لكن مرات عسكريه قبل شهر
من الان مع الفلبين كل هذه الافعال تدفع
بلا شك الصين للتحفظ والى النظر
الدول او معظم الدول محيطه بالصين هل هذا
ما يقصده او تقصده بالمخاوف او ربما هذا
الذي نسف اللقاء الذي كان يفترض ان يعقد
في سنغافوره بين وزير دفاع الصين ووزير
الدفاع الامريكي تحت تبرير المخاوف
النشنطن لا تسعى لي تبريد هذه المخاوف
يمكنك دكتور حمزه
نعم يعني اعتقد هذه يعني التحالفات
والقواعد والوجود العسكري الامريكي في
اسيا بالمناطق المحيطه بالصين كلها تعتبر
عوامل تهديد حقيقيه وجديه للصين للامن
القومي الصيني ولكن اعتقد ان هناك مرونه
في التعامل يعني بين الولايات المتحده
والصين يعني لا يوجد هذا يعني التهور او
الاستعجال في يعني الوصول الى صراعات
مباشره هناك يعني ضغوطات من الجانبين على
بعض العسكريه من جانب تجاريه من جانب
لتحقيق مكاسب للحصول على تنازلات يعني
سيبقى الامر بتقديري في هذا الاطار لكن
الضغوطات هذه مزعجه لانه سيكون لها
انعكاسات اقتصاديه وماليه على الصين وعلى
الولايات المتحده ايضا بالتالي هم في صراع
والتنافس
ويمكن يكون هذا له علاقه ايضا بالصراعات
او بالتوسع الصيني في الشرق الاوسط وفي
افريقيا ولها دور كبير والان تقوم بمبادره
سلام في اوكرانيا الصين يعني الان تنتقل
الى مرحله نوعيه جديده في نشاطها الدولي
يعني ليس فقط علاقات اقتصاديه وتجاريه
بصمت وانما الان تدخل في الساحه السياسيه
والجيوسيه
في هذا الخبر العاجل الان في هذه اللحظه
نقلا عن البيت الابيض يقول الاعتراض الصين
لطائره امريكيه هو حادث غير امن وغير مهني
ونريد المحافظه على قنوات اتصال مع الصين
طيب في سياق متصل ايضا هذا الخبر في اخر
فصول تبادل الاتهامات بالاستفزازات
العسكريه بين واشنطن وابيجين جاء على لسان
الخارجيه الامريكيه الذي اكد ان طيارا
صينيا اتخذ اجراء خطيرا باقترابه من طائره
امريكيه في بحر جنوب الصين التي اتهمتون
بتكرار ارسال سفن وطائرات المقاتله بالقرب
من الصين قالت ان طائره استطلاع الامريكيه
هي التي تعمدت اقتحام منطقه التدريب
الصينيه الخاصه بها في السادس والعشرين من
شهر مايو جاري اثناء تدريبات في بحر جنوب
الصين ما تعليقك على هذه الاستفزازات
المتبادله بين طرفين
يعني انا اؤكد مره اخرى على انه هذه
الاستفزازات المستمره القديمه والجديده هي
ستكون تدخل في اطار يعني
الضغوطات
ولن تؤدي الى حرب
يبدو يعني ان الدكتور خليل العناني لا
يوفقك الراي وهو يهز راسه لك التعليق
له سابق تاريخيه مثلا الحرب العالميه
الاولى قامت نتيجه لوجود او لقيام شاب
اغتيال ولي عهد النمسا ذاك الوقت اندلعت
في يثر ذلك حرب عالميه كبرى وبالتالي من
الصعب جدا توقع ان تكون هذه المسائل فقط
مجرد مجرد ضغوطات هناك بالفعل حاله
استنفار حاله تخوف حاله تحافظين ولكن خطاب
معادي في كلا الدولتين يعني مثلا هناك
خطاب وعادي جدا في امريكا تجاه الصين
باعتبارها خطر استراتيجيا على نفوذ
الامريكي في المنطقه
عدائي نوعا ما في الصين تجاه امريكا
باعتبارها تسعى للحد من الصعود الصين
الاقتصاديا وعسكريا تجاريا وبالتالي هناك
طرفين قد ينتج عنها مواجهه عسكريه
شامله دكتور حمزه هل هذا ممكن ما مقالات
هذا الصراع هل يمكن ان ينتهي بالفعل الى
مواجهه عسكريه
لا اعتقد وقال وقد ذكرته ذلك بان الحرب
بين الصين والولايات المتحده ستكون حرب
مدمره للعالم كله يعني عمليا
هناك في تنسيق بالمناسبه هناك قنوات اتصال
عسكريه بين البلدين لم تنقطع كما صرحوا في
الصين هذا صحيح وبالتالي هم كل هذه
الضغوطات يعني موجوده العداء موجود وخاصه
قمه الدول السبع الاخيره اكدت على ان هذه
الدول قلقه من النشاط الصيني ومن تطور
الصيني ومن السياسه الصينيه
يعني هذا
الات هذا الصراع
الصراع سيستمر بهذا الاطار ضغوطات عسكريه
مناورات ضغوطات تجاريه اقتصاديه حتى يعني
هناك سر توازن في العلاقات يعني هي تستمر
بهذا الشكل او اذا اذا اضطرت الولايات
المتحده الى دخول صراع عسكري فانها لن
تدخل هي بنفسها وانما قد تدخل عن طريق
وكلا توجههم الى الصين كما يحدث الان في
اوكرانيا وروسيا يعني الولايات المتحده
بشكل مباشر لن تنخرط في الصراع العسكري
وانما ستجد يعني قواعد هناك لها او مناطق
او دول او جيوش ولها حلفاء كثيرين في اسيا
ستشعل نار بينهم وبين الصين قد يكون بهذا
الشكل ولكن هذه ايضا ستكون لها نتائج
وقيمه على الاطراف كلها شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور محمود الحمزه الاكاديمي والباحث في
الشؤون الاسيويه كنت معنا من موسكو شكرا
ايضا لضيفنا في واشنطن دكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السي اسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
شكرا لكما وشكرا لمشاهدينا ايضا الى هنا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
لكم منا اطيب هنا والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]